Crystal Williams
“Year After Year We Visited Alabama”
After Jacob Lawrence’s
“There Were Lynchings”
The past has long legs
& is heavy, they said,
which was a kind of warning —
stay clear of the enormous
twisted tree on Tidwell Hill.
To we cousins the tree seemed fabulous,
a grand old heron,
wings stroking eternity,
the southern vista beneath it so soft
& innocent,
so dramatically green.
We were dazzled.
From there our lives
unfurled hypnotically before us:
we could be
doctors & principals, actresses, mayors.
We wanted to escape
their watchfulness & murmurings,
their relentless apprehensions
that seemed to want
to reign everything about us in,
our unruly hair,
our clothes,
& our brash voices & sauce,
even our childlike curiosities.
So we’d climb up,
lay on Daisey’s ancient red quilt,
play word games,
dream up novellas
about a mutant boll weevil
named Boll Winkle,
lamenting missing summer
in Detroit with our friends.
Truthfully,
we thought they were too southern,
too old school,
overly full of moon-gloss & doom.
In our imagination,
the past had no place among us,
certainly didn’t have
heavy legs,
was not resting on our shoulders,
& wasn’t hanging
from a twisted tree.
We also mistook their burgeoning pity
for disapproval,
the weight,
the growing tightness in our shoulders
as ephemeral & of only that place.